*générique de journal télévisé*
S: Eh bien bonjour ! Bonjour, à vous, qui venez de nous rejoindre je suis aujourd'hui avec Yann , comment allez vous ?
Y: Eh bien écoutez ça va très bien Lucas, j'espère que vous aussi vous allez bien, parce que là nous allons vivre un énorme moment....
S: dans...
Y: sportif.
S: Oui... Vous avez raison Yann.
*rires*
Y: Coupez moi la parole, il n'y a absolument aucun soucis.
S: Tout d'abord, mon cher Yann, je suis très heureux de commenter cet événement avec vous !
S: On a réussi à obtenir les droits, on est passé devant beIN Sport.
S: Euh... Qui s'en battez les couilles de l'événement.
*rires*
Y: Personne n'en a parlé en Europe
Y: Et là justement, nous, on est très content de pouvoir vous faire vivre les Tokyo OnlyPic de 2008, voilà, l’événement ...
S: D'accord...
S: C'est incroyable , Yann ! ATTENTION !
S: On me signale que tu dois te taire parce que  la cinématique d'ouverture commence ! C'est parti !
Y: Voilà !
Y: Le National Stadium de Tokyo
S: Ouais... Un stade qui a fait la gloire des plus grands !
Y: Voilà avec tous les drapeaux qui représentent bien évidemment les pays qui vont concourir à ces épreuves sportives...
S: Et sans surprise mon cher Yann.
Oh Yann ! C'est le compteur qui commence, la foule est en délire ! On peut l'entendre dans le casque ! On ne s'entends presque plus dans la cabine.
Y: Et c'est parti pour ces Tokyo...
S&Y: OnlyPic
S: 2008 !
Y: Oh c'est magnifique, comme je vous disais, le méga-pigeon, qui est l'emblème...
S: ...l'emblème, finalement...
Y: ...du japon !
S: Du japon et de cette compétition !
Y: Est ce qu'on peut dire que cette cérémonie, justement, ne vole pas très haut ?
S: C'est exellent... ce que vous venez de dire mon cher Yann
Y: Merci...
S: OH ! C'est le... l'athlète, très célèbre Egashira
Y: Ah, très très bel athlète !
Bien sur ! une célébration hors norme !
*musique de cérémonie*
*voix grave*
*rires*
*musique de cérémonie*
*voix grave*
*rires*
Y: Je crois qu'il est très heureux d'être ici  !
S: Voilà !!! Ah ! C'est Riichiro Mashima ! Bien sûr  président ...Il devait nous rejoindre , il a annulé tout à l'heure...
Y: Batard de Riishiro !
*parle japonais*
Y: Je ne comprend pas DU TOUT le Japonais
S: Ah ! elle amène la bougie dans le stade ! bien sûr
Y: Shoko Nakagawa
Y: On voit bien qu'elle court sur place, hein...
Y: Joli fond vert !
S: Nooon..
S: ...Vous exagérez Yann !
S: AH. Elle lui met le feu au cul
Y: C'est ça !
Y: John Benson ancien recordman du monde du 100 m, il va passer le relais bien évidemment à...
Y: D'accord *haha* il se jette dans la piscine bien évidemment !
A Lui Ming ! bien sur ancien vainqueur du  110 m haie
il va passer le relais au francais, le francais Jean Paul Pierre Casimir Poincarre
il transmet la flamme à Sergey Popovych
Et voilà, c'est parti Yann ! ohlala le logo apparaît dans la piscine, on va enfin pouvoir regarder la première épreuve, c'est parti, on y va!
*musique du GRAND JOURNAL*
Mon cher Yann bien sur on est a Tyoko, on est au Japon
En quoi
Les Japonais excellent
...Heu les sushis
Le Tennis de Table bien sûr mon cher Yann aller c'est parti
Nous sommes en direct du gymnase DICUDACAGUIMA
Bien sur EDYCADACHIBA attention
Au temps pour moi
*Bruit balle de ping-pong*
Ca va plus vite hein...
Au la la HO la la la  mais qu'est-ce qui ce passe Yann
Mais qu'est-ce qui ce passe de la part de nos athlètes ?
A qui le jury va décider d'accorder la médaille d'or ?
*Bruit balle de ping-pong qui rebondit de moins en moins*
Pour l'instant je reste, heu... Sur ma faim
Mon cher Lucas
Heu on ne saura jamais qui aura gagné Yann
Je dirait que sais le sport qui a gagné
Nos deux joueurs se sont littéralement heu...
Mangés la carotte
musique de générique
Il est maintenant temps de passer, mon cher Yann, à la balançoire
Oui, c'est une discipline extrêmement difficile
dans lequel beaucoup d’athlètes...euh... japonais excellent
Et je parle pas de...du tableur (Excel)
Alors que là c'est... les étirements de la part de Bobby la Banane
Voila, il se prépare
L'arbitre dit qu'il peut y aller. Il prend son élan...
Et c'est parti! Oh la la la la la la la.
Magnifique ! il a fait 1m90, il se place avant-dernier
ah, un fan club
C'est parce que le candidat hollandais a beaucoup de succès auprès de la gente féminine
Eh bien voilà. Oh que c'est bien parti.
Oh que c'est bien parti.
Est-ce que le rebond est pris en compte mon cher Yann ? Je l'espère.
Alors justement. On est sur les règles internationales
où effectivement le rebond est pris en compte.
Donc c'est vraiment la longueur du jet
6m70, il se classe premier. L'athlète Japonais
Très beau physique d'athlète
ouh, il est chaud ! *Bruit du japonais : YAHH*
OHH ! Oh mon Dieu !!
Mais comment a-t-il fait ? Il n'en revient pas lui-même !
Il est le premier étonné ! Il est le premier scotché.
Mais... mais où va-t-elle ? Où s'en va-t-elle mon cher Yann ?
*Vitre cassée* *Chien qui aboie*
C'est vraiment... Alors là Yann je crois qu'on a un record du monde.
Je dirais un bon 460m quand même.
Ohh je dirais plus dans les 600 mon cher Yann.
On est dans les 200, on est dans les 200.
Bon c'est quand même une sacrée performance ! Très belle performance.
Alors que voici, euh... notre candidat Ethiopien.
C'est le favori, normalement. Est-ce qu'il a des chaussures ?
Là ce serait... ce serait allé trop loin.
Parce que là, on voit pas le plan sur les chaussures et je pense...
...je pense qu'il n'a pas de chaussures. Voilà
Que s'est-il passé mon cher Yann ? Il a disparu.
Il est monté dans un arbre.
C'est... c'est scandaleux, ce... ce qu'on voit là.
Difficile, de commenter des clichés aussi racistes sur une vidéo mon cher Lucas.
*Musique des infos*
Mon cher Yann, tout va se jouer sur cette dernière épreuve : l'appel du Samouraï.
D'accord. Les athlètes vont être notés par rapport au cri du Samouraï qu'ils feront
Alors, David Joe, qui va s'élancer.
Alors je ne vois pas en quoi balayer le sable sous ses pieds va l'aider à mieux crier.
"S A M O U R A Ï Ï Ï"
*Applaudissement*
Ah, il nous a surpris, il nous a surpris l'Américain. Il avait préparé ses cordes vocales !
Ah, David Joe ici, fier de sa performance et il a raison.
Le Nigérien Erio Thompson qui s'élance.
*Mal de claquement des os*
Oh le claquage ! Oh le claquage ! Le claquage. Naaan !
Oh naaan !
Un si bel athlète ! Il a travaillé tellement d'années pour arriver sur cette finale.
Et c'est au moment où il allait son cri... Oh on le voit terriblement déçu ici présent le Nigérien !
Ok il n'abandonne pas, on s'est fait avoir.
Allez, all... c'est la souffrance quand même sur son visage.
Il va tout tenter
*Cri Samouraï
*Applaudissement*
Alors... *rires*
Est-ce que c'est la fatigue de cette vidéo Lucas ?
On peut dire que David Joe était bien meilleur, tout simplement.
Ah ! le japonais... le favori... qui fait son entrée.
Oh... Oh là là... Oh là là... Oh, il impressionne le public !
Ouais, généralement on sait que les Japonais sont plutôt discrets dans leur célébrations alors que là
c'est totalement à l'américaine !
*Préparation du cri Samouraï*
Il se chauffe la voix
Ouais, deux fois.
*Samouraï et claquement de mains en rythme*
*Claquement de mains du public et de S et Y*
Oh !
Mais que se passe-t-il à l'écran mon cher Yann ?
Je ne comprend plus !
*Cri du Japonais*
*Musique de guitare et paroles japonaises*
*Accompagnement de musique d'harmonica*
Je trouve qu'on va se retrouver pas mal de fois sur MalaiseTV
*rires* Grâce à cette vidéo.
Alors je sais faire quelque chose de plus impressionnant que cet homme
Voilà ! C'est mon passage préféré de la vidéo ! *rires*
Il est reparti hein. Y a pas eu de rappel mais il continu quand même. Allez c'est super ch*ant
Allez, ferme ta gu**le *rires*
*Applaudissements*
Et voilà, il vient de finir sa prestation.
C'était génial, mais le Samouraï call ne doit pas durer plus de quatre secondes.
C'est donc une disqualification, pour ce gros fils de p***.
Allez suivant.
*Musique des infos*
Mon cher Yann vous allez être content, pourquoi ?
Bah parce que c'est bientôt la fin !
C'est la cérémonie de fermeture ! Ouiii ! Eh oui !
C'était vraiment très très dur !
Très très dur, très très long. La cérémonie de fermeture
qui en faiteuhh... ponctue aussi
la fin de ce marathon, euh... de danseurs
Voilà, avec un danseur qui est un peu plus en galère
Je pensais sincèrement que c'était terminé
Hein, qu'on allait avoir deux trois pigeons qui se ch**nt sur la gu**le
Et qui euh... et en plus... C'est interminable mon cher Yann...
...Mais c'est interminable
Et là le bouddha va se casser la gu**le, ça va mettre le feu à tout le stade
Nan, il va décoller carrément, il se barre !
Il se barre, il se barre, il en a vu assez, il en a marre.
Voilà, il est aussi déconcerté que nous devant tout ça
Il va prendre le stade,
et l'envoyer en l'air bien sûr
Voilà, des milliers de morts
Qu'est-ce qui se passe dans la tête d'un japonais ?
Je ne sais pas Yann
Et il retourne finalement sur sa planète.
Plus jamais ça, Lucas, plus jamais.
*bip*
Eh bien mon cher Yann c'est maintenant l'heure de se déshabiller.
Ouais, complètement là, complètement.
Et de revenir à nos vidéos de puceaux *rires*
Merci à tous d'avoir regardé la compétition. N'hésitez pas à l'aimer si ça vous a plu
Mettez des likes pour qu'on n'en fasse plus.
Mais pas plus hein, vraiment plus on n'en fait plus
plus sans s
Un moment Yann j'ai même cru prendre ma cravate
et l'attacher à un spot, de manière à mourir.
Je t'en, je t'en aurais pas empêché.
Merci à vous et n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous à plu comme d'habitude.
Et on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine compéti... non, non, non
C'est fini, c'est fini, c'est fini. Plus jamais, plus jamais plus.
Yann est complètement à bout de souffle.
Comme la chanson de Section D'Assaut. Mais j'arrête pas de comparer
c'est incroyable.
Peace, urine ! Ça c'est la définition d'abréger ses souffrances c'est ça ? *rires*
*Chanson japonaise*